when we think about hackers we first
think about what was happening in the
early times of the internet so before
the mid 90s there was people having fun
and trying new things and the best
representation even if not the best
movie is the movie from 1995 maybe
hackers with a young Angelina Jolie as
well change everything yeah risk is good
because in this movie you can see also
them rollerblading going around with day
computers but now it's completely
different
that's because since the www has been
invented we had completely complete
revolution where everything changed and
where everything has been started being
stored and information being processed
and so and so forth on the networks now
also the banks are online well not only
now it's in lastik I'd say but that
means again that we have a lot of
important information a lot of money
stored through online online storages
servers and networks that could be
attacked it's not only for fun but now
hackers have a different motivation
there is money the hackers can try to
for instance in fact a computer in order
to steal information or change the
advertisements in order to put your own
that would be a loss of money for other
advertisers that wouldn't visualize
their advertisement and so on and so
forth so maybe not even the victim is
the infected computer but that is the
medium used to attack another computer
the idea today is to go through some of
these kind of infections just to show
what is the motivation why there is
money involved and what is important
about that the first infection I want to
go through is information stealing
Mawlid the two probably most famous ones
are Zeus and torpig but in general what
does the information stealer mouth do
the attack is when a computer is
infected they intercept all the possible
forms so this means they are going to
try to take all the single
forms you submit on the Internet a login
credential for instance a bank
credential and they will try to steal it
what happens is we have our computer
where we write the things and our
computer is infected now when we log
into a website for instance the bank to
lock there we have to send the
information that are our credentials so
login there is user and password this is
a form but because our computer is
infected the malware is going to
intercept this form and so the form will
go to the bank I will be also stored by
the malware at a certain point usually
as soon as possible in the moment it
intercept the forms the malware tries to
contact another machine that is usually
called command control server when it
intercept the form it sends it the
command control in order to make the
information available for the criminal
when this happens the criminal is able
to reuse this information to login to
your bank details for instance or to
take your Facebook credentials and log
into Facebook now is this valuable yes
it is while maybe mail or Facebook
credentials could be a few dollars if we
still for instance bank details or
credit card details this could be some
hundreds of dollars and obviously like
Zeus or torvik were stealing much more
than a few of them as an example the
torpig botnet that i mentioned at the
beginning it has been able to infect
over 100,000 computers per day it was
using another botnet nabrit for the
first infection and then it was managing
everything from the command control
service a problem with the first botnets
before torpig was that they were having
just one command control server or maybe
more than one but they were hard-coded
so that one infected machine was
communicating only to one command
control server in the moment you were
taking down the command control server
the infected machine was not able to act
anymore
the torpig botnet was the first one or
one of the first at least introducing
the domain generation algorithm
in order to find the domain where they
would have found a command control
server in a dynamical way during the
infection but what has been done by
researchers in 2009 was to
reverse-engineer the code of the topic
botnet in order to find out the
algorithm that was generation the domain
names because this was the first one was
pretty easy to find out how to identify
the domains before they were looked for
by the different clients the different
bots and in the moment they were about
to be active those domains would have
been taken by the researchers in order
to avoid that the command control server
would have been active and by doing this
they were able to avoid that the
infected machines were active because
they weren't receiving any instruction
and they weren't able to send anything
out because the command control servers
weren't at the domains they were looking
for this was the first time they've been
able to do something like that but after
some days then for the new infections
there was a new version of tor peak that
was not so easy to detect the domain
generation algorithm from there it has
always been a kind of arms race between
researchers and defenders and cyber
criminals in order to find out which
algorithm of situations were able to
generate the domains and being able to
prevent these kind of issues if you were
a defender a domain generation algorithm
has to have as output a string that is
the domain itself they have to kind of
randomize the generation of the string
and at the same time control this random
acceleration through put in some
parameters that would block to a certain
state in order to know what it is about
to be created in this way what is about
to be created by the bots will be the
domain that they know they can buy and
they can own in order to have the
command control server active where the
body is looking for it how did that
differ because surely then once it's
gone to that command control server if
you can see what it's communicating with
presumably you can stop it or is there a
way of making it move on to another
command and control server so command
control servers are usually active for
about a day maybe two so when we are
even able to identify one of them we
could put it down but most of the times
there is a new one going up after a day
and also now the most advanced botnets
are able to redirect when you don't have
the command and control server you were
communicating for to a new one so in
this way even if we put down one of the
command controls the bot would be able
to get the new command and control to
communicate with we may have a certain
quantity of infected machines that are
communicating to a command control and
the same is happening with other
infected machines and so on and so forth
for other thousands and thousands of
times now if we do put down this command
control apart from the fact that there
may be a new domain generated soon and
so another command control being well
the same command control been able to
take another domain and be inactive also
what can happen is that these bots that
have been infected but cannot
communicate here they are going to try
to communicate here or maybe to another
C&C that is here with other ones in
order to redistribute the load by having
different command and control servers we
have different little networks of
impacted machines that can be used in
different ways another kind of malware
from a malware family that is on the
edge now is ransomware as we have heard
there has been the one a cry attack for
instance recently and there is already a
computer file video on when a try and we
know that ransomware what they do is to
lock the computer and to encrypt the
data now first before the ransomware
they is already advanced there has been
screen lockers they were working more or
less in the same way but they weren't
encrypting the data that means that your
data wasn't affected but they were just
blocking yourself on that screen so if
like technicians were able to get out of
that screen you would have had to pay
the ransom in what happens since that
with ransomware is that what they have
is they lock the screen and they start
encrypting your data this way while
maybe you are looking at the screen and
you don't know what to do the your
computer gets encrypted and encrypted
and encrypted now there is an
interesting fact on psychology because
what they tell you is give me the money
there are also quite nice tutorials that
are linked about that and how to pay in
bitcoins for instance give me the money
and I will give you the key to the crypt
and the guide on how to the crypt with
that key and that's good if only you are
sure that this is going to happen and
you are sure that this is not going to
happen again with another infection
because what you don't really know is if
maybe you are able to decrypt but the
malware may still be there and maybe
activated further on so you will have to
pay again ransom for instance that's
obviously more money but also the
probability is what if I don't give you
the right key I may ask you again for
money for having another key but then
you may decide not to pay any more and
if I do it all the time people may not
want to pay me anymore so my whole
economy would crash so the idea is I
have to give you the key in order to
decrypt because otherwise you're going
to stop paying me there is what
suggested by the law enforcement for
instance and in this way I may want to
leave the malware there in some stealthy
way in order to be able to reuse it if I
want this could be particularly good for
criminals but that's why what law
enforcement say is have a backup and to
avoid problems with the backups now
ransomware
are also checking for local backups so
if you do a backup of your data on your
local machine this would be identified
from the most new malware samples and
the ransomware would delete the local
machine the local copy and you wouldn't
have the backup so what happens there is
that the backup has to be more on an
external hard drive or on the net but if
that is connected in the moment of the
infection that's again a problem because
ransomware tried to spread also over the
network apart from the wanna cry example
where there was a worm involved that is
another family of malware in general
ransomware look for
all the devices that are connected to
the computer that is infected and if
there is any device with a storage that
is connected for instance shared
documents in an office they would
encrypt also those shared documents and
that's obviously a problem because if
you have your external hard disk where
you have the backups that is connected
at the moment when the infection is
there the ransomware will try to encrypt
also that part that's also why when you
see a runs from your infection and you
know you have the backup what they
suggest you is to close as soon as
possible the computer by just taking out
the plug in order to avoid the
ransomware to continue encrypting
because the encryption part takes time
it's not an immediate process and they
need to let you stay in maybe trying to
understand how the pavement is and so on
and so forth but if you just plug off
then you can do the backup and obviously
you may lose the most recent data but
you would avoid paying a lot of money I
think it makes sense to just pull the
plug what would happen then I suppose is
not turned the computer on but take the
hard disk out I suppose and and get
someone d2 to deal with it if because
that's again against the economy itself
of the malware because if if you
immediately pull it off and you do the
backup over the encrypted data then the
malware can't do anything because it
would be taken out as you wipe the hard
disk from how it is and you put the
backup on and then the malware can't do
anything and it's just you disinfect it
and you didn't pay yeah I think the key
is was like you said is making sure none
of these devices are connected all the
time yes it's got a backup it's just for
doing the backup it's not because for
instance if you have your backup on
Dropbox just to make an example of a
crowd but you are still connected on
Dropbox all the time then what would
happen is that in the moment it infects
you it's able to get your Dropbox and in
fact your Dropbox part and it's not the
Dropbox responsibility but it's just
what happens and Dropbox would see just
as something that is changing on your
space but it's not something they are
managing but they think you are managing
it well it's the ransomware that is
infecting your computer and is managing
your drawer
at the same time I'd be interested to
see because Dropbox keeps deleted files
and if you change your files name I
wonder if it yeah I don't know I wasn't
very interested to try that because it's
possible maybe and I never tried it's
possible maybe that Dropbox keeps a kind
of record of what you have changed and
is able to restore maybe to the most
recent situation but I'm not sure about
that I never tried to do something like
that so sometimes he fought please wood
dies he often would make backup copies
let's try this one sounds more hopeful
and so there was this game called lambda
which became the full games arch and
when this game was released it was sort
of full 3d graphics which